Weighing in at 200,000 kg and
stretching the length of a basketball court,
the blue whale tops the big animal charts.
Now researchers think the seasonal availability
of its 40 million-krill- a day diet
may have led to their behemoth size.
What does the fossil record say?
Researchers knew from living whale proportions
that the size of a whale
correlates with the width of its cheek bones.
They then measured skulls of 63 extinct whale species
and of 13 modern species and
plotted them on a timeline
that showed the whale family tree.
The whales didn’t get to be really big early on.
Nor did they gradually get bigger over time.
Instead they become moderately large
and stayed that way until about 4.5 million years ago.
Then baleen whales went “from relatively big
to ginormous."
4.5 million years ago,
the biggest whales were only 10 meters long.
Blue whales today are 30 meters long, where
What was happening 4.5 million years ago?
It was the beginning of the first Ice Ages.
And as glaciers expanded, spring and summer run-off
poured lots of nutrients into the ocean,
fueling explosive growth of whale food.
That seasonal runoff
created a new pattern of food availability:
seasonal patches of very abundant food
spaced far apart over the course of the year.
Why would this make for bigger whales?
Modern whale studies show that
the more concentrated the food,
the greater the feeding efficiency,
especially in whales with really big mouths.
Furthermore, larger whales can travel faster
between patches of prey.
So baleen whales that got bigger, faster thrived,
while smaller species went extinct.
So for whale evolution,
it’s not quite “you are what you eat,” but close.